i'm steve ducey i'm dana parino i'm
tyrus and this is the fox news rundown
wednesday october 27 2021 i'm jessica
rosenthal more social media companies
are facing congressional scrutiny this
time over the way they handle content
for kids one of the things that is so
disconcerting to us is these platforms
know
that they are being abused
i'm dave anthony it's the newest member
of the fox family fox weather an app
that launched this week where they'll
even try to explain the unexplainable
there's no meteorologist that knows
every single thing you know mother
nature is incredibly humbling okay you
think you know something and then
magically mother nature does something
completely differently
and i'm guy benson i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
last week we saw a facebook
whistleblower come forward to tell
congress that facebook and instagram are
harming young people especially girls
francis haugen told the senate
subcommittee on consumer protection
product safety and data security that
facebook knows its products are harmful
but puts profits over people the
documents i have provided to congress
prove that facebook has repeatedly
misled the public
about what its own research reveals
about the safety of children
the efficacy of its artificial
intelligence systems and its role in
spreading divisive and extreme messages
facebook ceo mark zuckerberg said during
an earnings call this week that good
faith criticism helps them get better as
a company but my view is that what we're
seeing is a coordinated effort to
selectively use leaked documents to
paint a false picture of our company
tuesday the senate subcommittee that
heard from haugen grilled the public
policy heads of some other social media
platforms tick tock snap and youtube
specifically about how they moderate
content for and market to minors
snapchat was built as an antidote to
social media snap vp of global public
policy jennifer stout said they're
automatically deleting content a
camera-based app rather than a
text-based feed and the fact that both
snapchat users must opt in to
communicate with one another makes
snapchat different but tennessee
republican senator marsha blackburn said
a man who sexually assaulted a teenage
girl in memphis connected with her on
snapchat they used the snap
map
location service
and i know you're probably going to say
only your friends can follow you but
somehow people are getting around that
and these sexual predators
who are following young people are using
this map to get to their location there
were some tense exchanges as well over
what proposed legislation regarding
privacy marketing and content management
the companies would back like this one
between massachusetts democratic senator
ed markey and youtube's head of public
policy leslie miller senator again we we
are already doing this
consistent no we we're trying to draft
the law here would you support that
provision being in a law that prohibited
it
senator yes as as we already prohibit
targeted advertising
yes after pushing all three companies
over a proposed bipartisan law to amend
social media liability protections over
how well these companies protect child
exploitation online the subcommittee
chairman senator richard blumenthal said
generic support of ideas without
commitments just isn't good enough i
joined in the frustration felt by many
of my colleagues that
good intentions support for goals
endorsement of purposes is no substitute
for
actual endorsement so when will all the
talk end and actual regulations be put
in place i will tell you i'm quite
pleased
that we are beginning to coalesce around
language for a federal privacy standard
an online privacy standard marsha
blackburn is a republican senator from
tennessee and the ranking member of the
senate subcommittee on consumer
protection i've worked on this issue now
for right at a decade
and it seems that people are beginning
to say yes we need to have individuals
opt-in if they want to share
their information
they would have the ability to prohibit
a platform from using that information
unless they give their explicit consent
also the platform could not boot you off
the platform if you decide to hold your
information
private
then we would have one set of rules for
the entire internet ecosystem with one
regulator the
ftc and there seems now to be agreement
on those provisions so federal privacy
online privacy legislation should be
coming forward
before we get to the end of the year
at tuesday's hearing members from both
parties seem to be largely on the same
page about you know marketing to young
people content they shouldn't be viewing
there's so much bipartisanship that the
senate judiciary committee if i'm
correct passed an act that would base
social media companies liability
protections on how well they root out
content that exploits kids
and yet at tuesday's hearing many of
your colleagues grew frustrated with the
company executives for being you know
non-committal when it comes to actual
legislation so my question is why does
it matter so much
if these companies are on board with
what you guys pass especially if there's
so much bipartisan agreement on what's
needed
we know what they've been doing we know
that the children's online privacy
protection act coppa is something that
is on the books they
as you can hear from what we are hearing
during these hearings what these uh tech
platforms are saying they're fully aware
that they're functioning outside of the
law
and they're very non-committal
because
they
don't want to get upside down
and cause themselves further problems
and they're trying to capture
younger users not lose these younger
losers to a competitor it is all about
chasing the dollar
and so they're going to sit there
and tell little white lies
and try to cover themselves so that they
don't get
get caught but as you can
have observed from the hearings we're on
to them and that is why we're going to
pass privacy legislation data security
legislation you mentioned the section
230 reforms which deal with liability
which deal with preferencing of products
which deals with censorship
of post and of different sites and
information
and it is why on a bipartisan basis
we're going to move forward on
legislation
i want to turn to
tick-tock and china i want to get your
thoughts because um tick-tock's parent
company bike dance is a chinese company
and as you noted in the hearing just
this year tick tock's privacy policy was
updated to say they may collect
biometric data i believe you focused in
on that asking why they would need such
data including keystroke patterns
also
it's i think it's important to note tik
tok is still a private company unlike
the others
did you get an answer to that question
why they need this biometric data or
keystroke data or did you end up coming
to a conclusion on your own based on
information you obtained at tuesday's
hearing
because tick tock's witness did not want
to give a direct answer to me or to
senator cruz
about this
you have to
make the um
the judgment call
that yes indeed they are capturing all
this biometric data your face prints
your fingerprints your voice prints
um
they are capturing
conversation that is going out over
uh your speakers
to your iphone into your devices
and they are building a copy of you
online
i call it your virtual you
so what they're trying to do is own your
virtual you
and by
capturing and
correlating your search history your
keystrokes your patterns
then what they're doing is
uh replicating you
so that they can predict when you're
going to pick up your phone what you're
going to do with that device or phone or
what's going to happen when you log in
and what they should be populating your
screen with
when you log in
it is an enormous
violation of your privacy
and they say well it's all done by
algorithms now
with tick tock as i mentioned in the
hearing their parent company is bike
dance
their that company
is owned in part by the chinese
communist party
they purchased a stake in bike dance
this year and have a chinese communist
party member
sitting on the board of bite dance well
but no that's an affiliate right yes and
there is doyin
that is also an affiliated company
to bike dance and whether it is bike
dance or bike dance
china
what you're looking at is a
grouping of companies
now
to make it worse
um
some of the u.s data that tick-tock has
is housed housed in the u.s
and in
singapore and until recently
that data in singapore has been housed
by alibaba which is a chinese-owned
company
so the question is and the question they
would not answer is what is happening
and who has access to that data
is it bike dance is it bike dance chat
china
is it doing
uh
is any of this data
moving into china because you have
programmers and engineers that are
housed in china
and whether it was senator cruz senator
sullivan
or me
there were not straight answers given to
those questions
senator cruz did get the representative
from tick tock to confirm that bite
dance is considered to be part of their
corporate group and that's important
because the tick tock privacy policy
says we may share information we collect
with our corporate group however when he
felt he didn't get a straight answer on
whether a white dance affiliate was also
part of a corporate group he said this
that does not give this committee any
confidence
uh that that tick tock is doing anything
other than
participating in chinese propaganda and
espionage on america that's not accurate
that's an intense accusation to make do
you agree with it
yes because they would not answer that
an american's data
the data of our children is safe
in tick tocks care
and
parents want to make certain that their
children are not going to be exploited
online and as senator klobuchar brought
up there was someone that she represents
a family that she represents
that a child had been put in touch with
a drug sale
a drug purchase that was made by over
tick tock the connection was made over
tick tock
we have so many examples of harm that
has come to children i have someone from
memphis
that
a child was participating in a tick tock
challenge a strangulation challenge and
the child died the child was nine years
old
and these are
these are harms
that are there in what these social
media platforms call the new public
square bear that in mind
but they don't want to conduct
themselves in a manner that says they
have respect
for the people that are participating in
the public square
senator blackburn thank you so much for
your time thank you
[Music]
this is guy benson with your fox news
commentary coming up
this week started out rough for a lot of
us dealing with some really bad weather
now i'm just terrified
every time the wind picks up now i'm
scared she is still repairing her
burlington township new jersey home from
hurricane ida's remnants and a
nor'easter dumped a lot of rain flooding
some areas there up to new england
tornadoes did damage from missouri to
illinois and out west they got drenched
by a weekend storm sacramento california
got 17 inches of rain the most ever
recorded there in 24 hours a week
earlier sacramento had set a city record
of 212 straight days without rain
and this was another problem burn scar
flooding occurs when all the vegetation
is burned off on the hillsides and
because these fires they destroy the
trees the vegetation the duff on the
forest floor that can help soak up the
rain vegetation also holds the soil in
place so mudslides and other erosion
issues can be a problem that's max
gordon on scene in feather river canyon
california for
fox weather a new free app that just
launched monday you know what everybody
does not get a chance to make history
meteorologist jason frazier is a co-host
on fox weather live stream programming
weekdays from 6 to noon eastern you know
anytime you start a new business or a
new venture like this you just never
know what the reception is going to be
and it was fantastic to look down in the
apple eye store yesterday and we saw
that we were the number one downloaded
app we were beating tick-tock so you
know that is a response not only to the
fox brand but you know what people had
expected us to do and i'm so so proud i
cannot say it enough of our team
and how much we have supported one
another how many different ideas that
we've thrown up against the wall and
said hey we're going to try this we're
going to try this we're going to try
this but you know ultimately our mission
is to not only change the way that we
have deliver weather ultimately we want
to make sure that we save lives and you
know people know exactly what to expect
whenever severe weather happens in their
neighborhood
you know you the weather channel's been
around a long time and so you're going
up against you know something that's
been established for a very long time
but when you guys watch the weather
channel did you guys think you know they
really ought to do this or we can do it
so much better by this and that is that
part of it
so i think any time in business you know
you look at something and you say hey
you know we might be able to do things a
little bit differently or you know
there's an opening there's there's an
opportunity here and you know i think
the beautiful part about fox is we've
always approached stuff uh and said you
know let's do this differently i look at
the way that we tackled you know nfl
coverage i look at the way that we have
attacked news
we are always bringing a different edge
as something that was more creative
and
you know shameless plug here and talking
about the app i think one of them one of
my most favorite things about the app is
something called future track which
nobody else has
uh the cool part about future track is
if you have an event let's say it's a
birthday
or an upcoming vacation you can put in
that location you can name it whatever
you want
and we will automatically give you
updates on the weather up to almost a
year in advance
so kidding not only do you have a
countdown that you know you can
periodically check up on but you also
know exactly what to expect there's
nobody else on the market right now
that's doing that um and do you know how
cool that is you know when you have a
nice little uh vacation a little beach
vacation that you know you're planning
uh you know with your spouse or the kids
and you know you can just go right in
there and you you know exactly what's
going to happen no absolutely and i mean
all of us so we're going somewhere
especially if it's somewhere warm in the
winter time we're checking to see what
the weather is at that place but to have
it already there is cool absolutely you
know we also have this thing called 3d
radar uh which is also a new thing as
well that is definitely cool looking
yeah so if you have not uh had a chance
to look at the app the cool part about
3d radar is you can look into a storm
and see how tall a storm is generally
speaking the more severe storm is the
taller the storm is
we've actually color-coded it as well so
the darker shades of a color whether
it's green or red that indicates that
the storm is a lot more severe
than other storms and the other cool
part is you can track exactly where that
storm is uh in your neighborhood or
let's say you want to check on a storm
for what's happening with grandma's
house
it's not in a two-dimensional um it's
not in
it's not in 2d as i like to say it's in
3d
so you know that is something that again
isn't on the market this is all free of
charge this is an ad-supported app the
other cool part about the app is the
live stream so again dave shameless plug
here uh with that live uh stream you can
watch us for six hours from 6am eastern
standard time to 12 noon eastern
standard time and
i will say our broadcast is unlike
anything other uh that that's out there
as well you're going to see a mix of
weather news stories weather forecasts
and we're also going to throw in a
little fun as well
yeah that's the thing too with uh with
fox personalities a big a big factor in
it you know and and for you
when you were getting this ready i know
you guys were working on this for a
while
um getting to know
the you know your co-anchors is key yeah
yeah and
i look at it as a marriage right you
don't want to marry the wrong person
because otherwise you know it's going to
be a long day and
i probably spend more time with my
co-workers here than i do with my actual
wife you know on a daily basis
so you want to make sure that you like
each other that you're in tune with one
another and you know the beautiful part
about my colleague britta is i feel like
we balance one another steven also is
the same way we all bring different
things to the table um you know i bring
more of a news background because
previously i was a reporter and i became
a news reporter a a i should say
meteorologist so i'm always looking for
the facts i'm always looking for you
know what is the one or two things that
people really need to know you know both
brita and steven uh they're they're
scientists you know so they're always
breaking down kind of the science
portion of the storm what do you need to
know what don't you need to know so you
know it's the perfect blend
this was a big week to launch you you
guys had it wasn't just you know nothing
going on for a week and you had to make
it up you had on both coasts these big
big storms especially the one that was
over the weekend out in the pacific and
over in california especially
that was really something and there was
a term that i really didn't know
atmospheric river
yeah it actually sounds really cool but
i know it's it's it's it can be a lot of
a big problem yeah and for those that
don't know what it is uh this happens a
lot of times in in california where you
have a shift in the jet stream and it
acts as kind of like a gasoline pump it
moves moisture from
the pacific ocean where it's warm all
the way throughout the pacific northwest
so that's why they tend to get a lot of
rain in october and even into november
so just so that everybody who has no
idea what dave was just talking about
what that is
i didn't know what it was either i was
like what the heck is an atmospheric
number yeah no no no we the other the
other one we had to explain uh uh this
week was uh something called
abomogenesis and people think we were
making that up and i said no no we're
actually not making it out is that the
same thing as the bomb cyclone
they're they're used interchangeably so
they're within the right family but
basically it's it's all about a storm
rapidly intensifying um that that that's
pretty much the the gist of it and so
you know whenever you get a whole bunch
of meteorologists together you know we
do have a direct line into uh mother
nature so we knew that if we were going
to debut a a new weather network you had
to plan it right we had to plan it right
you know there was no way
you know we could have uh you know been
just talking about sunny skies but you
know they tell you to show you how crazy
it is if we would have debuted last week
when half of the united states uh just
had sunshine and high pressure was in
control you know what uh it would have
created some really i'll say boring tv
you know well you guys that's what see
that's where you earn your paycheck see
that's when you've got to make the tv
not boring even though the weather's
boring right uh that that's true and and
you know most people don't realize this
but 250 you know out of you know 365
days out of the year you know there is
no severe weather so you know this is i
think where you know you will maybe see
our uh our coverage shift a little bit
you know we will be a little bit more
news oriented you know in terms of some
of the star wars stories that we cover
so you know it might be you know a
potential where you know instead of
maybe spending five minutes on a
forecast about what's happening in the
um you know in louisiana you will maybe
see a three or four minute story about
how louisiana is recovering from ida and
what are some of the concerns there my
colleague robert ray he did an excellent
piece about the wetlands
you know about what was happening there
and the scientists that are really
trying to build up the wetlands you
might be wondering what lands why do i
care well i call it nature's natural
buffer whenever you have storms that
move off of the atlantic ocean they
usually pack a lot of rain and you
prefer that rain to fall in a wetland
versus on actual land so if you don't
have wetlands where does all that water
go it goes in the city centers this is
why it's cool and there are i noticed as
i went through the app there are there's
a whole section of like learn videos so
there's a lot of stuff that was even
like why snowflakes are bigger some
snowflakes are bigger you know seven
facts about snow
what's a blizzard that and that's very
cool because i kind of geek out
sometimes on things like that you know
yeah and listen i will tell you that
there is no meteorologist that knows
every single thing you know mother
nature is incredibly humbling okay you
think you know something and then
magically mother nature does something
completely differently and you know it's
an imperfect science but i have found
that most of the audience is incredibly
understanding
when you explain exactly what has
happened why it happened and what you
learned
you know there's sometimes it's been
politics and weather there's been a lot
of talk more more and more over the
years so and now again in congress and
the climate change you're a
meteorologist do people ask you about
climate change people do yes people
people all the time you know ask us
about about climate change look it it is
real uh climate change is definitely
real um and the beautiful part about fox
weather is we are going to cover it
we're going to cover every single story
it's tough because you know it gets very
political you know depending on on your
view of climate change so how do how how
will you deal with that well i think
it's about just stating what the facts
are you know uh it's stating that look
during hurricane ida we had nine inches
of rain in one part of new york city
that is not normal why is that happening
i think when as a scientist you learn
not to really approach them from a
political stance you just state what the
facts are and you let the audience
decide for themselves and i think you
know many times you know people want to
say hey i'm this or i'm this or i'm this
and i think that's where you turn off
people i think if you were just the
reliable news source that just gives
people the facts people will keep coming
back all right well it's certainly
something big and starting new this week
fox weather meteorologist jason frazier
who is also co-host of fox weather
sunrise and sky dome during the week 6
to noon on the app jason congratulations
good luck and thanks so much for being
with us thank you
[Music]
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite fox news talk
shows live swipe right for the latest
fox news radio newscasts on demand fox
news radio and the fox news app download
it today subscribe to this podcast at
fox news podcast
it's time for your fox news commentary
guy benson benson
what's on your mind the new york post
has reported that president joe biden is
finally building the wall no not a wall
at the southern border a wall around his
vacation home in delaware the report
states that the department of homeland
security has allocated nearly half a
million dollars to build additional
security fencing around the beach house
in rehoboth i have no problem with this
of course he's the president of the
united states there are security needs
there are undoubtedly threats against
him and secret service has to do their
job no issue there but is it not
interesting that at joe biden's vacation
house it's been determined that building
physical barriers to prevent
unauthorized access is an effective
strategy of keeping people out the byte
administration despite presiding over
one of the worst border crises in our
history continues to insist that they
will not construct a wall at the border
and progressives often echo the refrain
that walls don't work they plainly do
which is why they're building one at
chateau biden there ought to be a lesson
there this is guy benson host of the guy
benson show
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
hey it's brett larsen inviting you to
download and listen to the new daily fox
on tech podcast there's part of a
colorful late 90s imac on mars it's an
idea that seems a lot like kickstarter
called build it subscribe and listen now
by going to foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you get your podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes